fyi one thing to be thinking about which
is pretty interesting
uh uh
is
while the moment the attack started this
morning the moment the attack started
this morning fyi the moment the attack
started this morning so it's very
important to know ethereum skyrocketed
today
it went up
okay when the war started ethereum went
up okay
it was down to 300 it went up to 27.50
okay
why
are people feeling a little more safer
and crypto with their money today i
don't know
is that where a lot of the money moved
bitcoin moved in the last eight hours 12
hours from 34 000 to nearly 40 000. what
caused it right that's a complete
different conversation that adam you can
investigate to talk about on your show
that's blown up right on valuetainment
money sauce cast you may want to
disclose that and see what it is maybe
investigate that a little bit more are
people feeling a little bit more
comfortable going into the crypto side i
don't know all i can say is uh the
economy is going to be affected just so
you know the military industrial complex
that they talk about they're going gonna
make so much money right now the the
president of uh uh of uh uh ukraine said
we're giving away free guns hey if
you're willing to stay and you're not
escaping because all the gas stations
are lined up people in ukraine are so
afraid they're leaving
where the president of ukraine said
we're willing to give you a free weapon
if you stick around if you stay for
chrome we're going to give you a weapon
but the question everybody's asking is
where do i get the weapon from i'll
stick around but where do i get it so
there's a lot of you know
not miscommunication lack of proper
communication for people that want to
stay and fight for their country but
they can't get it and they've already
taken over a small airport
who knows what's going to be happening
here but there's going to be major
effects around the world with this the
question is this is going to work or not
well you bring up a really good point
with a theorem with bitcoin and if you
looked at this stock market and
obviously the stock market is not the
economy and economy is not the stock
market but it's a good indicator
this morning everything was in the red
obviously since the attacks on uh
ukraine from russia everything was red
it's a little after four o'clock right
now pat i'm going to get your thoughts
on this
dao up 92 s p up 63 nasdaq up russell
2000 up bitcoin up big ethereal up big
amazon tesla disney nvidia apple
facebook google everything's up
including
um
treasury bonds
you would assume
when a potential world war three is
about to happen
a a
a groundbreaking groundbreaking war
across the world
that when the when everything went into
the red this morning it would continue
for the day if we're not days after
based on your business acumen why would
the stock market and every major index
go up from here what are your thoughts
i will tell you this biden looked very
strong today
biden looked very strong today okay you
have to know what we talked about on
this show is we're going to talk about
what we see we're not sitting here
defending one side or another biden
looked strong today and that gives the
american people a lot of confidence you
know a lot of times a political
strategist will say anytime you're
losing and you're you're what is it uh
your uh polls are down what's the what's
the word you're um
uh uh uh when the
the support president
your wife not your base you're losing
your base
no no not got your base when the support
the president's getting that poll
everybody looks at the favor when that's
down yeah say that again your popularity
your favorability your popularity but
your popularity uh
uh percentage is down your vote is down
people are not like they're not feeling
good about this guy right now what's
that
approval rating is what i'm telling
approval rating is down
um
there's a few ways to get it back okay
one of them is a war because it is a
strong position that you have okay but
this is not a war that biden started
okay this is not a war that america
started right this is an opportunity
that this man's been capitalizing off of
[Music]
you